you're as happy right now as you're
going to be
when you achieve this thing in other
words achieving the thing is not going
to make you happier it's just going to
put you back in the state that you're in
right now and achievements in that sense
is like an amplifier of whatever you're
feeling right now so if you're feeling a
sense of misery right now and you
achieve something amazing
the wave of Joy will pass and you'll be
back miserable again but if you're happy
right now if you feel fulfilled right
now and you cultivate that then you can
achieve things and you'll still be
fulfilled and maybe even it'll inform
you which goals you go at having
fulfillment now will make you think okay
well this opportunity is not aligned
with what I'm feeling inside so I'm
gonna even though on the surface it
looks glittery it looks amazing but I'm
gonna pass that one and I'm gonna go for
this one that doesn't look glittery but
it is aligned and you move in that
direction and usually that's where
amazing things start happening in your
life